[Music]
what was this it's hilarious what's he
doing so alex fine
you know what's funny he manages to when
he just does these stupid things i saw
his video yesterday and i thought what
an inconsequential stupid thing
nothing's going to come with this it's
just him being silly
was that wrong
up so
alex stein was in dc
aoc's walking by aoc my favorite big
booty latina i love you aoc you're my
favorite
now initially she walks up because she
liked the compliment she wants to kill
babies but she's still beautiful
what
he's right on both counts
well maybe not beautiful but she's you
know
she's congressionally a 10 right she's a
congress 10.
yeah but she's like a yonkers eight
you look very beautiful in that dress
you look very sexy look at that booty on
aoc that's my favorite big booty latina
this is so
i'm very uncomfortable
i'm i'm i am i am loving this but also
crazy very uncomfortable so it's she she
is so mad bro she got this blew up she
was trending you know alex i was
trending yesterday right
i let it can i give you a little selfie
so nothing and then the other person
just told her who he was that's what
you're seeing and then it became bad
then he became a bad guy
i can't do this
i can't do this okay
oh no i met back i didn't mean to go
back okay here we go
i love it my favorite ao
let's see nice to meet you look how sexy
she looks in that dress
oh i love it aoc
hot like a tamale okay oh god i'm so
uncomfortable
that's the clip
it's very uncomfortable
very uncomfortable alex you're [ __ ]
mad man now
there's a lot of little highlights by
the way yeah the freeze frames and the
memes have been amazing that right there
favorite big booty latino
um
i like the laser eyes one the guy
followed me up the capitol saying look
at your juicy ass you let you uh
latina a bunch of other disgusting
garbage in front of an officer would let
him continue so i'm just going to share
this photo here since there's no other
protection ladies and it's here's the
problem aoc you're just mad that he
won't sleep with you yeah that's what it
is is that what it is is that is that
what it is is that uh she deleted this
tweet
here is a video he posted to the
incident i was actually walking over to
deck him because
if no one will protect us then i'll do
it myself but i need to catch a vote
more than a case today
yeah she deleted that
i wonder why
and as royce brought up on the air
wasn't she the one telling everybody go
bug kavanagh go bug all these people
that's right follow these people into
the bathrooms and stuff yep she loves it
but when it happens to her
this happens
hey everybody i'm here in the capitol um
see this guy right there
by the way alex stein always has
the most white boy drip going on right
have you ever seen him not in complete
white boy drip oh [ __ ]
right there
he when i was walking up
um
he said raped me
oh my god
uh
now hear her tale of the situation
versus what we saw happened okay
right in front of a capital police
officer hey
uh
here's this look at that big ass look at
that big juicy booty
latina like whatever you know all the
bunch of
racist sexist stuff wait i'm sorry
nobody can do anything what's racist or
sexist about it
he complimented you
he said you had a juicy latina butt i i
don't see the problem with that how does
that mean i mean is it was it a little
too forward sure
but did he touch you or did he just
yeah that's a good point she just cat
called you basically he didn't like he
didn't hurt you
i'm just telling you because
she's just telling you
her millions of instagram followers
just you oh no no they're called simps
oh you're right
by the way you know who was standing
extra whole time her white fiancee who
did
nothing [ __ ] boy he did
nothing
cause he's a little [ __ ]
this institution is not designed to
protect
here it is
people
you mean you you mean the system's not
designed to always protect the royalty
hey guess guess guess what your founding
fathers specifically built it up
that the system was here to protect
us yeah
not you
and the system has always been that
we're allowed to say
whatever we want to you people that's
part of your job as long as as long as
it doesn't contain the sentence
i'm going to kill you everything else
like that trevor skit yeah the only
thing i can't say is i'm going to kill
you other than that we're allowed to say
anything else we want to you that's part
of your [ __ ] job because you're a
servant
you're a public and by the way so serve
alex stein
yeah [ __ ] seriously get on your knees
and you serve our good friend alex
hey can somebody photo can somebody
photoshop aoc on the cover
of the spinal tap album [ __ ] school
[Laughter]
where's the girl on all fours and he's
got the leash on her
but she has the graduation calf one
and it's really hard and it's really sad
that my only recourse
is to just let you know about it but
what do you want to do have him killed
yeah you want do you want me to ashley
babbitt situation
seriously do you want him shot like
ashley babbitt do you want him beaten in
the streets by the way she plays this
like street tough latina chick but she's
from yonkers heights and [ __ ] like she's
from bucket but she tries to play all
tough but then she's a little she's a
little girl who's all scared now oh what
were you scared because they
complimented your big booty
oh what happened
were you weren't you like half half the
city away when the [ __ ] january 6th
thing came on you were talking about how
scared you were
oh no oh help alex knights harassing me
she's like oh my god i was so terrified
on january 6 they were surrounding me it
was like you were at a panera bread yeah
[ __ ] seriously
stop
oh [ __ ] dude did you see laura i was
telling you laura ingram
laura ingram was going in to [ __ ]
defend
to defend uh aoc
first off laura ingram somebody alex
pointed out lauren can we should take
keith olbermann by the way just keep
that in mind
um
they're afraid
um here it is
uh here i'll put it love so you guys can
see it okay
this guy is a total loser
but today decking a creep who deserves
it
may mean being charged yourself
what hey laura are you not even aware of
other things that going on on your own
network like he just did it in a one
hour with tucker carlson today and more
people saw him on fox today then she saw
you on your own network
that's a really good point
[ __ ] you lauren go seriously [ __ ] you
what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] she is
right
imagine that would be my [ __ ]
comeback if i got to be on tucker even
for five minutes
like if hannity said [ __ ] to me on
twitter i'd be like bro
i was seen by more people on your own
home network today than you were how
does that make you feel calm down buddy
[Laughter]
um
so yeah that's pretty much the uh
the whole scenario or you could be like
i was on infowars today so i was seen by
more people than any of you guys would
[ __ ] on the network
that's a really good point
i mean [ __ ] you should come on revenge
of the sis at least you're getting seen
by more people than would be if you were
on cnn or msnbc
murder it still sucks man okay now i
have president i have breaking news
aoc
got just right now aoc got alex stein's
gig that he had he was doing a comedy
show
in dc she called the place and got it
cancelled
wow she she's gonna really reveal her
pettiness huh uh alex stein aoc got my
d cart district of columbia arts center
to cancel my comedy show tonight full
refund for the people that bought
tickets if you still want to see me
perform come to the capitol tonight
at 9 30. alex
i love this man
alex i love this man i just wanted to be
careful i love this man
holy sh this is like just now [ __ ]
oh my god i love alex stein
he's a madman he's a [ __ ] madman
what the [ __ ] aoc
your
show
canceled
probably her people probably called
i mean that has to be it right her
people called and said this guy was
harassing and we don't want we shouldn't
be and that's all it took this is gonna
this is going to spiral into something
that's gonna really make her look poor
this she's gonna look bad because the
problem is is that you have some but
this isn't her you have time at work to
be making all these petty phone calls
this isn't her arguing with some like
old white dudes like where she's the
cool bartender this is her argument with
another young guy who's
look
cooler than her right
and she doesn't know how to handle it
she wants to be miss i could take the
jabs i could take the barbs i'm a strong
woman and then she goes and cancels his
gigs
jesus who the [ __ ]
who the [ __ ]
does what is this dc now and i gotta
know what this [ __ ] dc dc art center
hold on oh they're getting hammered
right now on twitter so that's good by
the way if you guys want it's at dc arts
center one word on twitter
what a vindictive [ __ ] you're a
vindictive [ __ ] aoc you know that
you're a vindictive [ __ ] yeah and this
is uh but he's exposing that which is
great oh no of course no i think that's
a good thing but it's just sucks about
his gig but i have a feeling he knew
he'll be fine he's gonna be performing
at the capitol i can't wait to see that
you're [ __ ] nuts bro